tenemos la ecuación diferencial derivada
de ye respecto de x es igual a ye sobre
6 por 4 menos y lo que hemos graficado
en el lado derecho es el campo de
pendientes de esta misma ecuación y lo
realmente podemos verificarlo por
ejemplo podemos dibujar una tabla de la
siguiente forma ponemos x verdad vamos a
poner algunos valores de x vamos a poner
también algunos valores de i y vamos a
ver cuánto vale la derivada de con
respecto de x en cada uno de estos
puntos x
entonces por ejemplo podríamos empezar
en este punto de aquí este punto de aquí
es el 1,1 verdad entonces si nosotros
sustituimos x igual a 1 igual a 1
tenemos 1 en 36 que es un sexto por
cuatro menos uno que es 3 entonces
tenemos 3 sobre 6
me dio verdad entonces podemos ver que
la pendiente es positiva y es un medio y
es más o menos lo que aquí mismo se
puede apreciar ahora bien es muy muy
fácil de ver que en realidad este campo
dependientes no depende de la coordenada
x es decir si nosotros nos movemos a lo
largo de esta línea que es considerar
distintas equis pero una y fija que en
este caso es 1 tenemos las mismas
pendientes verdad y eso es justamente
porque del lado derecho no tenemos
ninguna dependencia con respecto de x
verdad de lo único que depende desde y
entonces podríamos tener x igual a 24
menos uno tal vez podríamos tener muchos
valores de x y todos valen lo mismo
porque depende del ayer verdad entonces
no se podríamos a verificar con algún
otro punto por ejemplo el 1
6 digamos y entonces nos vamos al 16 y
vemos que si está inclinado pero hacia
abajo verdad cuánto vale bueno si
tomamos de igual a 6 tenemos 6 sobre 6
es 1 que multiplica 4 menos 6 que es
menos 2 verdad entonces nuevamente esto
realmente no depende de la equis
entonces tenemos una pendiente menos 2
en todos estos puntos verdad en toda
esta en toda esta línea muy bien
ahora realmente tú puedes verificar por
tu cuenta que en efecto este campo de
dependientes es el correspondiente de
esta ecuación diferencial digo podría
seguir tomando distintos valores de jr
ya vimos que realmente no depende de la
x puedes tomar varios valores de jay
seguir viendo que estoy el campo
dependientes corresponde a esta ecuación
diferencial ahora lo que queremos hacer
es utilizar este campo dependientes para
visualizar las soluciones que pasan por
ciertos puntos por ejemplo qué pasaría
si nos tomamos el punto este de aquí
digamos el 0,1 punto 5 nuestra intención
ahora es querer graficar la solución o
las soluciones que pasen por ese punto
entonces más o menos uno puede ver que
pues por aquí se verá de alguna forma
parecida ok y que cuando estemos en este
punto la gráfica debe ser paralela
digamos a estas a estas pendientes de
aquí verdad entonces a medida
que va aumentando esto se va viendo más
o menos de esta forma y entonces creo
que se ve cada vez más claro cuál es la
utilidad de este campo de pendiente es
verdad porque más o menos nos da un
esbozo de cómo deben ser las soluciones
que pasan por cierto punto verdad y esto
se ve como que se va extendiendo hacia
el cero verdad ahora qué pasa si nos
vamos hacia atrás de a partir de este
punto que habíamos elegido al inicio si
nos vamos hacia atrás entonces esto se
ve más o menos que hace algo así verdad
qué pasaría por ejemplo si tomamos otro
punto digamos al 6,2 digamos a este
punto de aquí entonces por el mismo
argumento verdad más o menos se tiene
que ir viendo creo que debería pintar
y algo más o menos de este estilo verdad
o menos de este estilo y hacia atrás es
el mismo argumento verdad mismo
argumento más o menos se ve de esta
forma y se ve que más o menos de esta
solución se debe ir pegando hacia abajo
de esta forma entonces realmente todo lo
que hemos hecho aquí es repetir el
argumento no sabemos cuál es la solución
a esta ecuación diferencial en cada
punto verdad pero al menos tenemos una
idea de qué tipo de soluciones
satisfacen esta ecuación diferencial
verdad entonces realmente hemos
analizado qué pasa si nos tomamos una y
digamos entre 0 y 4 y es bastante
interesante pero por ejemplo qué pasaría
si nosotros nos tomáramos ye igual a 0
digamos no sé
bueno más bien igual a 4 por ejemplo qué
tal si nos tomamos un punto en igual a 4
nosotros podemos ver que la pendiente 0
siempre verdad es 0 siempre la pendiente
entonces siempre nos estamos moviendo en
esta línea verdad siempre estamos
en esta línea muy bien entonces esta es
la solución correspondiente
un punto con ye igual a 4 y y si
consideras ye igual a 4 por ejemplo de
este lado de la ecuación diferencial
tenemos 4 menos 40 por 4 entre 6 manual
es cero verdad entonces del lado derecho
vale cero y como la con la ley es
constante su derivada respecto de x es
cero entonces justamente esta es una
solución verdad que satisface a la
ecuación diferencial y otro que
podríamos ver es esta solución verdad la
solución de igual a cero más o menos así
se ve verdad porque otra vez del lado
derecho que hacer hoy del lado izquierdo
al derivar una constante nos da cero
verdad entonces también estas dos son
justamente soluciones de la ecuación
diferencial pero bueno por ejemplo
podríamos tomar otro tipo de condición
inicial por ejemplo podríamos ver qué
pasa si si nos tomamos una condición
aquí verdad entonces vemos que hacia
atrás va creciendo va creciendo va
creciendo si nos vamos hacia atrás pero
a medida que vamos
aumentando en x verdad esto va
decreciendo decreciendo decreciendo y se
va pegando a esta línea verdad por
ejemplo otro otro caso que podríamos
considerar es una condición inicial acá
si nos vamos hacia atrás ahora ocurre
que aquí se va pegando hacia la línea y
de igual a cero verdad y nos seguimos y
va decreciendo decreciendo decreciendo
verdad entonces espero que esto te haya
dado una idea de lo interesante que son
los campos dependientes y tenemos una
ecuación diferencial como en este caso
que en principio puede depender sólo de
x de iu y bueno por supuesto de la
derivada entonces podemos graficar el
campo y que realmente no es mucho
problema como ya hemos visto y ahora
podemos esbozar cómo se ven las
soluciones a partir de algún punto que
queremos estudiar